[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le débat
politique du week end
ce soir on va parler bien sûr du départ
d'edouard philippe de maquignons
remplacé par jean castex d'abord connu
pour avoir été le monsieur déconfinement
d' emmanuel macron une nouvelle tête et
un nouveau chemin détaillé par emmanuel
macron dans la presse régionale ce matin
on va en débattre avec nos invités jean
paul huchon président honoraire du
conseil régional d'ile-de-france et
florian philippot président est des
patriotes bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être avec nous sur verte et france
un remaniement qui n'est pas une
surprise toute la semaine le chef de
l'état s'est entretenu avec son très
populaire premier ministre ex premier
ministre peut-être trop populaire
d'ailleurs peut-être est-ce lui qui a
préféré partir
on va en parler après sa victoire à la
mairie du havre dimanche dernier edouard
philippe a donc présenté sa démission
démission du gouvernement ce matin puis
passation de pouvoirs à matignon dans la
foulée à jean castex un homme de droite
comme lui peu connu au départ comme lui
mais sans la barre mme séquence émotion
regardez il vous appartiendra à monsieur
le premier ministre désormais de
continuer à servir la france ou la
servait depuis bien longtemps
c'est une belle responsabilité
alors je suis un peu ému en vous disant
cela mais soyez bon
et comme on dit chez moi bon vent
je mesure cher edouard l'émotion qui est
la vôtre dans la solennité de cet
instant comme chacun dur s imagine la
mienne au moment où je prends ces
lourdes fonctions
et voilà donc pour cette passation de
pouvoir qui a eu lieu il ya quelques
minutes florian philippot une réaction
sur ce choix de jean castex tout d'abord
je crois que c'est véritablement le
souhait des manuels macron de reprendre
la main de rejouer à l'hyperprésident
parce qu'il prend un profil si vous
voulez montrer passe muraille est
d'ailleurs moi c'est quelque chose qui
m'a rakim a quand même frappé il lui a
tout de suite imposer son directeur de
cabinet ce le même qu'il avait essayé
d'imposer il ya trois ans à edouard
philippe et edward fifa avait refusé
nicolas revest alias le il l'a bien
connu puisqu'il était ensemble
secrétaire général adjoint de l'elysée
auprès de françois hollande en 2012 s'il
arrive à lui imposer son directeur de
cabinet qui est un personnage clé auprès
du premier ministre bien sur ce lien
qu'il veut avoir la main il a
probablement les probablement très gênée
par la popularité acquise ces derniers
mois par edouard philippe
il veut pas que ça se reproduise et donc
là il a mis un profil somme toute très
monde d'avant on n'est pas vraiment là
dans le monde d'après on est vraiment
dans le monde
le monde d'avant voir d'avant-hier quoi
et quand vous êtes avant-hier on
al'impression effectivement que jean
castex un peu edouard philippe
au début du mandat des d'emmanuel macro
et edouard philippe qui a gagné 16
points en quatre mois il est très
populaire
est-ce qu'il lui faisait de l'ombre jean
paul huchon selon vous il était devenu
gênant jean castex aura plus docile je
dirais pas ça je pense que ce qui se
passe je suis toujours passé sous la
vème république
on vit avec deux hommes le président le
premier ministre et au début si tout va
bien ou d'un moment il ya une espèce de
fronde des entourages qui explique
l'autre a dit des choses qu'il n'aurait
pas dû direct tira et commence un petit
moment de détestation et au bout du
compte
moi j'étais absolument certain que il
partirait il doit rire parce que ma
croix de le faire souffrir
dans la période mais petit à petit et il
était devenu pratiquement impossible qui
continue ensemble la question c'est pour
faire quoi
parce que quand on regarde l'interview
de mâcon et se perd quoi il le semble se
diriger un soi-disant nouveaux chemins
qui râle je n'ai rien vu de vraiment
très nouveau les retraites reviennent on
est là effectivement à prendre c'est une
continuité hélas terriblement statique
alors même le local a été fixé
effectivement par emmanuel macron dans
la dans la presse quotidienne régionale
ce matin le cap semble à peu près le
même le chemin pour y parvenir par est
différent florian philippot mais jean
castex finalement va appliquer une
politique c'est un homme de droite
est ce qu'il va pouvoir incarner en tout
cas ce changement que chemin prônée par
emmanuel macron non mais y aura
évidemment aucun changement de chemins
et de toute façon vous savez qu'on soit
étiqueté de droite ou de gauche ils
appartiennent au moment où on appartient
à l'union européenne à l'euro on mène
toujours la même politique
en réalité quel que soit le président et
premier ministre c'est toujours la même
politique donc
donc moi je m'attends à un changement de
cap fondamentalement le jean paul huchon
a raison de parler des retraites nous
parle également la réforme épouvantable
de l'assurance chômage et donc on voit
bien qu'on va continuer
et le problème c'est que là on va
affronter une crise historique
on nous annonce quand même une récession
à double à -12 % ce qui est absolument
phénoménale on n'a pas connu ça en
france depuis au moins un siècle du lido
un chômage qui explose
et pourtant ce sont les mêmes vieilles
recettes en restant d'ailleurs avec les
mêmes dans le même moule dans la belle
union européenne avec l'euro etc
je vois pas pourquoi ce qui n'a pas
marché il ya marcherait demain moi c'est
ça qui m'inquiète je rebondis sur ce que
disait jean paul huchon tout à l'heure
je suis parfaitement d'accord je pense
ils ont fini par se détester je pense
que travailler avec emmanuel macron ça
doit être particulièrement insupportable
le personnage est quand même
et quand même très particulier on l'a vu
dans cette triste coronavirus la dame
dit réaction tout à fait inattendue il a
une psychologie à mon avis très
compliqué âge là alors effectivement
emmanuel macron qui a dit qu'il
maintiendrait en tout cas cette réforme
des retraites
on les écoute justement cet extrait de
cette interview de la presse quotidienne
régionale et on en débat après cette
réforme ne peut pas être prise de
manière inchangée à la sortie de crise
mais la question du nombre d'années
pendant lesquelles nous cotisons de me
reposer donc relancé cette réforme des
retraites que les français ne veulent
plus et c'est lâche vivo qui posait
problème s'était incarné par par edouard
philippe
ça va sauter sur vos questions à tous
les deux des coutumes inscrite au bail
on va y venir on va y venir ils vont
nous représenter sa durée de cotisation
et c'est ce qui risque d'ailleurs de
rendre la réforme à nouveau aussi
impossible qu'elle était je pense que là
le gouvernement le président aurait dû
prendre un peu de temps avant de le
ramener cette réforme des retraites
que veut-il prouver qui s'est engagé que
il tient ses promesses il ne tient pas
ses promesses
donc tout ça me paraît assez mal parti
avec un socle électoral qui est qui est
très comment dire est réussie parce que
l'alliance des socialistes et rolande et
géologie ce fait que le socle du
règlement ne raconte encore plus étroits
aujourd'hui sur tout ce qui
lille je continue dans le sens de
réformes assez plaisante comme celle
qu'ils ont et comment tu ont commencé
alors vous parlez des réformes visent
également le nucléaire sur lequel
emmanuel macron un maintient le cap
également regarder ce qu'ils ont dit
on en parle avec vous feriez filet pour
juste après jamais je ne supprimerait du
nucléaire pour remettre de l'énergie
fossile
car ce serait accepter plus d'émissions
de co2 supprimé du nucléaire a du sens
quand on peut le substituer part du
renouvelable non intermittents et quand
on voit que les français réclament
davantage de mesures pour l'écologie
florian philippot est là aussi on voit
que le cas finalement ne change pas
beaucoup
voilà emmanuel macron vient de démontrer
l'inversé de ce qu'il dit puisqu'on à en
fermer fessenheim parce que nous venons
de faire là le 30 juin
nous n'allons pas pouvoir remplacer les
personnages parlent uniquement du
renouvelable
c'est une farce c'est une farce ça
n'existe pas ça aujourd'hui
donc évidemment qu'il y aura plus de
fossiles par importation en france
essentiellement peut-être qu'on se
mettra à faire d'eux comme le fait
l'allemagne depuis qu'elle a fermé son
nucléaire on va re réouvrir des
centrales à charbon
donc s'il ya les discours et à la
réalité très dogmatique très idéologique
antinucléaires qui s'est exprimée avec
fessenheim et il faut s'arrêter là parce
que c'est une
c'est une folie sur sur le reste sur les
retraites je partage l'avis de jean
collection c'est une folie de rouvrir ce
dossier
maintenant même chose pour l'assurance
chômage alors qu'on va avoir deux
millions de chômeurs en plus à moi qu'on
veuille plongé le pays dans une misère
noire
on peut appliquer la double peine c'est
à plus de chômeurs en plus ils sont plus
mal traités
pareil pour les retraités moi je pense
qu'il ya des chantiers urgents là il ya
le chantier énormément de la
relocalisation notre production
industrielle ça ça me paraît être un
chantier absolument urgent dont on
parlait beaucoup il ya deux mois pendant
le confinement j'ai l'impression qu'il
va tuer le match on l'a déjà oublié
mais la réalité c'est quoi la réalité
c'est qu'il ya une feuille de route
décidée par bruxelles
on appartient à la bouille est unique on
appartient à l'euro donc on fait du
libre échange et donc on fait toujours
la même politique jean iv jean castex
edouard philippe ou un autre il ya le
secteur de la santé également qui est
sur la table qui a été reporté à cause
de ce remaniement
jean paul huchon justement est ce que
jean castex a les épaules selon vous
est-ce qu'ils à prendre des coups avec
ses réformes qui vont de nouveau revenir
sur le devant de la scène
est-ce que vous m'entendez jean paul
huchon répondait pas aux baltes je pense
que est ce que jean castex va prendre
des coups est ce qu'il est là pour
prendre des coups finalement d'ici à la
présidentielle
bonjour apparemment on a un petit
problème de son avec jean paul huchon
alors florian philippot est ce que c'est
comme ça que ça se passe en politique
justement sur cette fin sur cet acte iii
d'emmanuel macron s'ils tentaient qu'il
y ait un acte iii est ce que justement
on place un premier ministre qui fait
office de fusible finalement pour faire
campagne
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que le pot jean
castaings qui sort en avoir plein le dos
parce qu'on va rentrer dans le dur mon
avis une rentrée sociale dans 70 qui va
être très dur et on voit bien on a vu la
france on a vu et revu c'est à mon avis
on en est que on en est qu'à l'apéritif
à on en est là la mise en bouche on va
avoir une série de plans sociaux très
très très dur est donc le premier
ministre là je pense que mâcon sera très
heureux d'avoir un premier ministre
effectivement qui pourra être fusible
c'est quelque chose de classique dans la
vème république
mais faut pas qu'ils sous-estiment le
fait que les douars philippe a
capitalisé sur une grosse popularité
vous l'aviez mentionné tout à l'heure
magali sur une montée de 16 points vous
avez dix ans en quatre mois et loire
philippe lui sera retiré sur son aventin
sur sa ville du havre et il faudra
éventuellement pourquoi pas essayer
d'incarner un recours
voilà en tout cas il peut on peut lire
parfaitement l'imaginer je pense que
macron à ça aussi en tête et c'est un
problème politique il va devoir gérer
dans les mois qui viennent c'est évident
quant à un recours
c'est à dire un retour possible un
recours en coin à 20,6 macron par et
cabossé usées pour être un nouveau
candidat en 2022 parce que quand même il
n'a pas fait preuve le projet des
français dans ce quinquennat d'une
remarquable activité et que vous avez à
côté son ancien premier ministre
protéger de la crise parce qu'il n'est
plus que maire du havre et donc c'est
plutôt tranquille pour lui il n'a pas de
responsabilité nationale mais il
conserve une bonne popularité il n'est
pas impossible que des marcheurs de
député en arche qui ont envie de se
faire réélire en 2020 de se tourner
plutôt à la fin de la loire philippe qui
bon c'est quelque chose qui est tout à
fait possible et on avis c'est un calcul
que peut avoir entre edouard philippe
et c'est une crainte que peut avoir
également à l'esprit emmanuel macron
jeudi parcours sur le fond parce que
pour moi il n'y a pas eu les doigts
refile un quart ne pas du tout une autre
politique de mêlée je pense que renferme
le dom et de capacité à être candidat en
c'est un problème à mon avis qu'il faut
pas évacuer edouard philippe n'est pas
mort au contraire il a beaucoup
capitalisé ces derniers mois sur une
popularité en réalité il a égalé en
popularité parce que mâcon s'est
effondré et est donc par contraste et
bien il a gagné et c'est aujourd'hui un
problème pour macro jean paul huchon
c'est vrai qu' edouard philippe pétain
un candidat enfin qui était un ancien
premier ministre de droite c'est le cas
aussi pour jean castex ça agace quelque
peu la droite on va regarder ce qu'on
dit xavier bertrand justement et on en
parle après je connais et j'apprécie les
qualités de serviteurs de l'état de jean
castex
elles seront indispensables dans les
moments difficiles que nous allons
connaître
puisse-t-elle corriger les mauvais choix
du président de la république
voilà un xavier version qui n'y va pas
de main morte qui apprécient on le voit
jean castex mais quand même c'est une
nouvelle prise à droite c'est un calcul
politique pour les présidentielles de la
part d' emmanuel macron je crois que ce
qui se passe là c'est qu'on va avoir un
pot ministre qui est un petit peu comme
chez sarkozy
un collaborateur c'est quelqu'un qui
n'est pas vraiment un premier ministre
pas un homme politique et de la fiba et
finit par une démission une diversion
politique mais son tempérament n'était
peut-être pas non plus de devenir tout
de suite candidats la pizza et puis je
crois que c'est la droite qui doit se
poser la question parce qu' elle ne va
quand même pas laisser de raffi pourra
venir en majesté pour servir des
monnaies mâcon pis aux prochaines
élections présidentielles donc c'est ça
se joue beaucoup au sein de la droite et
de ses prétendants est une autre chose
que j'ai remarquée métier tout à fait
foudroyante
on vient d'une élection municipale ou de
l'écologie a quand même hâte et des
points rien n'a été dit aujourd'hui en
tout
car sur la place corps à l'écologie et
la question qui va se poser sur tous les
sujets de l'écologie aujourd'hui qui va
les porter avec quelle force lan
prochain jury
on peut en douter on se doutait on sort
la semaine prochaine cette question de
l'écologie qui a marqué des points
pendant les municipales et sachant que
ce sont les républicains qui ont
remporté le plus de mérite et non pas
les écologistes qu'on met sur un
piédestal florian philippot cet
électorat les républicains c'est c'est
là où emmanuel macron a envie de 2 visé
juste en tout cas pour pour sa
réélection
il faut quand même remarquer que le
premier vainqueur des municipales sont
d'abord les abstentionnistes dans des
60% l'abstention second tour donc en
fait tout raisonnement politique sur les
résultats des municipales se fait sur
40% de votants ce qui est quand même
faible est effectivement vous avez
raison en réalité dans nombre de villes
et vers des grandes villes donc c'est
marquant et c'est quand même une
victoire incontestable le mans mais dans
les villes moyennes s'est pris tôt les
autres partis l air et ps qui conserve
conserve les vivats pâtirait pas un
intérêt extraordinaire
le maquereau nous affaire à dix voies
sont là pour le parti présidentiel et
réserves de voix elles sont le maquereau
a déjà largement pris des voix samuel r
était tombé à 8 % aux élections
européennes l'an dernier parce que parce
que tous les maquereaux compatibles et
ils quasiment étaient déjà partis tous
ceux qui sont plutôt bien comme lui
libéral européiste etc
ils sont des îles ont déjà l'intérêt à
voter macron enfin il ya pas beaucoup de
différence donc est-ce qu'il a d'autres
réserves
moi je pense qu'il devrait essayer de
remettre les abstentionnistes audio mais
je pense que les milieux macron en fin
de mandat n'a plus du tout la capacité
de convaincre les abstentionnistes
transit sont dégoûtés de ce système
politique et ils veulent à mon avis une
révolution politique ils veulent quelque
chose de complètement différent
jean paul huchon est ce que vous y
croyez au monde de demain dont emmanuel
macron a donné quelques détails dans la
presse régionale est ce que ce sera
différent du monde d'avant selon vous je
ne vois rien de très différent encore
une fois sur l'écologie va rien se
présenter 2 foudroyant
sur le chômage et la crise économique
on est on est vraiment dans
l'expectative et enfin sur la question
importante organisation du pays de la
décentralisation du rôle des élus etc
je pense pas que mâcon est décidé de
faire une révolution dans ce domaine au
contraire c'est d'avoir c'est contraire
à son tempérament puis d'autre part
aujourd'hui tout le monde s'en méfient
donc il n'y aura pas de grandes
nouveautés n'y aura pas de grandes
envolées et c'est ça va être une fin de
mandat très difficile avec une situation
économique qui comme le disait tout à
l'heure
varian depuis pau et quand même
calamiteuse boire catastrophique et on
ne sait pas moi je constate à dans mes
pérégrinations que l'économie n'a pas
vraiment repris il ya encore beaucoup de
gens qui sont l'armé au pied et ils vont
bientôt être guettés sérieusement par le
chômage
donc tout ça ne laisse pas augurer une
rentrée triomphale et ce remaniement me
paraît un peu comment dirais-je sous
dimensionné un peu faible par rapport
aux autres ambitions par actif de se
réinventer du président sous dimensionné
vous êtes d'accord florian philippot
fait oui non mais s'il voulait
absolument pas on voit bien que macron
pense qui va gérer tout seul manière
glorieuses selon la haute l'idée qu'il
se fait de lui-même cette prise de
l'historique qui sera à la hauteur de sa
destinée imagine-t-il enfin c'est un peu
ce qu'on sentait dans ses discours un
peu délirant pendant le pendant le
confinement on comprenait pas bien ce
qui voulait dire il parlait lui même en
fait plus que de la situation française
est donc il met une armée de
technocrates avec un technocrate en chef
à la tête jean castex pour être ses bons
petits soldats mais on voit bien qu'il
n'y aura pas deux ils comptent pas sur
ce gouvernement est content assure ce
premier ministre pour changer quoi que
ce soit il compte sur lui même et on va
il fait une grosse erreur parce que
l'hiver est un homme du passé
il a un logiciel idéologique
mondialistes ultralibéral européiste qui
est complètement dépassé par les
événements
et qui ne permet pas de comprendre le
monde le qui vient jean paul huchon le
mot de la fin pour vous jean castex a
été un proche de nicolas sarkozy est ce
que il faut y voir une certaine
influence de la part de l'ancien chef de
l'état sur emmanuel macron pourquoi pas
mais je crois pas que ça ça ça la
question la question s'il fallait qu'il
se dote d'un poids et miss au fond on va
dire plutôt plutôt neutre politiquement
plutôt à droite bien sûr et si il ya le
fameux choix de d'une nouvelle étape
sociale etc
bon il n'est ce pas c'est clair donc
qu'à sexe c'est un espèce de tout
premier ministre à mon avis merci
beaucoup dont ce sera le mot de la fin
je vois que vous êtes d'accord
florian philippot merci à tous les deux
en tout cas d'avoir participé à ce débat
c'est la fin de ce débat politique du
week end merci à vous pour votre
fidélité rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]